So
Waske, let's see if we can
manage the Queen's Indian sheep here, at least it's playing in the
classic way. Yes, Petro's
variant of the sequence is, I think,
unusual  The knight
has put up a bit of a chrum,
so the knight should aim for F4, well
I would now probably rather
yes like this and now F5 yes, that's already
possible
F5 yes you should probably do it
as long as you get around to it, that
's
more often that knows how to play with H3 and
so but that's a bit strange
here with Queen
C2 in terms of tempo the position seems a
bit strange to me for for
white so wait a minute what about F4
F4 take bishop C5 and then G3 is that an
idea he has bishop E3 ​​no
probably  not not good,
what else can you play now I
can play Queen E8 or F or
knight back to F6
I do F4 Bishop C5 DC that
should be bad yes it also looks
strange Queen
E8
which was taken
okay he probably wants a
position with maybe takes it  He's even going
away now in the hope that
he'll get the eternal knight on E4
so
t so then I have to clarify now
I think
structurally it looks good at first
for white but aha
not at all again
t not at all again
yes  Does he want to play G4 first
probably
yes
H
yes you don't know no if I
play G4 now I can maybe
even take it or is that too
risky so I don't really see anything
against it I control the
F-file yes
knight E4 yes H5 stop
no, it's still a bit far here too elt
mm
okay, yes, well, I don't have much choice now,
so there's a
threat of something happening now,
yes, I don't really see
it yet. Somehow Hal is always just chess, so and so to have the structure clean
So F3 is
n't really one yet, I can even play Rook F3.
I don't think I can see what's threatening then,
really, well,
I don't know, it looks good, I do
n't see any big options for
him, so yes, he might want to swap the queen now
yes, I still have
E4 and then make my own bishop
really long. Does it have
any great stories? I do
n't see it
Zero number is yes and of no
use at all Knight F6 could
be there I can also move the king
oh I blind fish what did I
see then I wanted to hit C4 oh man
how unnecessary from this super fat
position
hey God God God how unnecessary I could
just do normal ones
Of course, moves are also nonsense nonsense with Sosa
but I don't have time
weak inspiration oh man how unnecessary that
was totally was easily won this
position pawns no more for
nothing
yes I'm stupid I'm stupid I'll take a
quick
look Nonsense what
nonsense I can just swap the queen
and  then King F7 and he ca
n't take H5 because of Rook H8 and then
it's just over. The Habauer
simply wins the game very easily
with the two bishops supported, that's
nonsense, I just
had a hallucination here that Queen G1
is good,
well